cartes de crédit en main johnstone yole
fait le plein d'énergie pour son
véhicule il fait partie de ces convertis
de la voiture électrique et surtout de
son coût d'utilisation
30 à 40 $ d'électricité par mois dit il
c'est une fraction de ce qu'il en coûte
pour les voitures essence mais il est
loin de représenter la majorité des
automobilistes
en 15 ans les canadiens ont acheté entre
60 et 70 mille véhicules hybrides ou
électriques
mais pendant la même période
26 millions de véhicules à essence et
depuis cet automne grâce aux prix plus
avantageux de l'essence la tendance se
poursuit
peter jackson aime les grosses
cylindrées il a une camaro sa femme un
romain et son fils un camion léger
aujourd'hui il veut s'acheter sept
grosses berlines puissantes une cadillac
au diable la dépense dit-il il veut du
luxe et de la performance son
concessionnaire vendeuse à trois
véhicules par jour et avec le prix de
l'essence actuel les clients n'hésitent
pas
ils achètent plus gros dit il parce
qu'ils peuvent maintenant se le
permettre grâce au prix de l'essence cet
expert du marché automobile le confirme
aujourd'hui les camions légers les
véhicules utilitaires sport et les
véhicules multisegments représentent 60%
des ventes de nouveaux véhicules au
canada pour les écologistes c'est le
côté sombre du faible prix de l'essence
ça rend les énergies renouvelables moins
compétitifs face à l'essence qui est bon
marché
les gens ont tendance à acheter
davantage de véhicules qui consomment
plus comparativement des petits
véhicules
mais comment convaincre les
automobilistes de ne pas succomber aux
bas prix de l'essence greenpeace pense
qu'il faut en profiter pour imposer une
taxe sur le carbone partout au canada il
ya une marge de manoeuvre plus grande
pour les consommateurs il ne verrait pas
de grand impact à mettre rapidement une
taxe sur le carbone et on sait qu'il
faut le faire de manière greenpeace
rappelle qu'une quarantaine de
gouvernements de divers paliers ont
instauré ce type de taxe la colombie
britannique est un des pionniers dans le
domaine depuis 2008 la taxe sur le
carbone représente entre autres près de
cette scène par litre d'essence fait à
noter entre 2008 et 2013
la consommation des carburants fossiles
a baissé de 16% dans la province alors
qu'ailleurs au canada et le augmenté de
3%
mais cette taxe n'a pas changé
fondamentalement les comportements des
automobilistes puisque les sens c'est
toujours la reine sur nos routes au
grand désespoir de notre amoureux de
l'électrique
et ce qui n'aide pas sa cause c'est
l'efficacité énergétique des véhicules à
essence qui ne cesse d'augmenter 7
litres aux 100 km sur route 10 litres en
ville ces gros véhicules consomment de
moins en moins
il constate qu'entre 2007 et 2014
l'efficacité énergétique des véhicules
les plus populaires a grimpé de près de
20% bref les consommateurs peuvent se
sentir moins coupable
robert charles qui lui a sa solution
comme sur les paquets de cigarettes il
veut afficher sur les pompes ces
messages de sensibilisation
pour être plus conscients de
l'environnement dit-il
quelques pompes de la municipalité de
west vancouver seront d'ailleurs bientôt
dotées de ces avertissements
probablement une goutte dans l'océan des
sens qui continuent d'alimenter la
plupart des véhicules
sur nos routes ici frédéric arnould
radio canada vancouver